c'est le japon qui est enseignante en
adaptation scolaire à l'école curé
antoine labelle de laval elle est aussi
entraîneuse de l'équipe de futsal et
maman et l'entrain de ces jeunes hauts
depuis neuf ans elle les a vus grandir
au sens propre comme au figuré
celui ci en particulier son gardien
trendy des sources
et cette année la photo d'équipé a des
airs de photos de famille parce que
depuis un peu plus d'un 1 prennent 10
habitent avec jade et son conjoint
l'ancien quart vedette du rouge et or de
l'université laval benoit groulx et de
coopération
la première est avec moi supporter pour
les problèmes il représente la même
chose que petits garçons représentent
ici ou à la journée qui est rentré chez
moi j'en ai pris soin comme système
l'enfant fille l'adolescent de 17 ans ne
connaît pas son père biologique est à
peu près pas sa mère
il habitait en famille d'accueil jusqu'à
octobre 2010 est bien dû en être retirée
d'urgence le lin shi rejoindre ça ne
devait être que pour un week-end mais
n'est jamais reparti janet benoît sont
devenus ses tuteurs légaux
ça a été beaucoup d'émotion je pense que
c'est le fait qu'on devienne tuteurs
légaux nécessairement chances que cette
lettre qui lui assure que c'est fini
c'est fini changer si peu après
l'arrivée de président la famille s'est
agrandie
madonna aujourd'hui sept mois la famille
c'est vraiment important pour eux ready
s'est métamorphosée il a pris du coffre
et a fait le plein de confiance en lui
il a cessé la médication qui le
prenaient pour des discuter des tensions
et s'affaire maintenant amélioré son
dossier scolaire
la différence c'est que je sais plus
comment moi même si j'ai pas prêt à
parler avec les portes cachées qui ont
été limités par un de primes s'ils sont
dans la jeune trentaine et travaillent
tous les deux en milieu scolaire benoît
est entraîneur de football ou collège
charles lemoyne à longueuil
ce encore plus les fans parce qu ils
sont encore dans mon monde à moi fait je
peux parler comme système des amis
et preuve que la normalité s'est
installée prennent dix vit les mêmes
frustrations caunes adolescents de son
âge j'avais pour toi qu'est ce qu'elle
représente vous
corvée passait vraiment c'est quand
c'est juste range ta chance d'y être
nous un prof à la vaisselle ou va
promener un chien
ces jeux seul problème et en appelle la
famille groupe m6 s'apprête à passer un
premier noël à 5 mg à la fille de benoît
se joindre à eux
c'est un beau geste pour lui m'a même
pas pour moi
on a là dessus c'est une bonne chose
olympic
on est très fort chez les groupes
laitiers la définition d'un joyeux noël
prendra tout son sens cette année
ici antoine et réseaux canada laval
[Musique]